- [Instructor] What I would
like to do in this video
is to see if we can prove
that triangle DCA
is congruent to triangle BAC.
Pause this video
and see if you can figure
that out on your own.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So let's see what we can figure out.
We see that segment DC is
parallel to segment AB,
that's what these little arrows tell us,
and so you can view this segment AC
as something of a transversal
across those parallel lines,
and we know that alternate interior angles
would be congruent, so we know for example
that the measure of this angle
is the same as the measure of this angle,
or that those angles are congruent.
We also know that both of these triangles,
both triangle DCA and triangle
BAC, they share this side,
which by reflexivity is going
to be congruent to itself,
so in both triangles,
we have an angle and a
side that are congruent,
but can we figure out anything else?
Well you might be tempted
to make a similar argument thinking
that this is parallel to that
'cause it looks parallel,
but you can't make that
assumption just based
on how it looks.
If you did know that,
then you would be able to
make some other assumptions
about some other angles here
and maybe prove congruency.
But it turns out, given the
information that we have,
we can't just assume that
because something looks parallel,
that, or because something
looks congruent that they are,
and so based on just
the information given,
we actually can't prove congruency.
Now let me ask you a
slightly different question.
Let's say
that we did give you a
little bit more information.
Let's say we told you that the measure
of this angle right
over here is 31 degrees,
and the measure of this angle
right over here is 31 degrees.
Can you now prove that
triangle DCA is congruent
to triangle BAC?
So let's see what we can deduce now.
Well we know that AC is in both triangles,
so it's going to be congruent to itself,
and let me write that down.
We know that segment AC
is congruent to segment AC,
it sits in both triangles,
and this is by reflexivity,
which is a fancy way of
saying that something
is going to be congruent to itself.
Now we also see that AB is
parallel to DC just like before,
and AC can be viewed as
part of a transversal,
so we can deduce that angle CAB,
lemme write this down, I should
be doing different color,
we can deduce that angle CAB,
CAB,
is congruent to angle ACD,
angle ACD,
because they are alternate,
alternate interior, interior,
angles, where a transversal
intersects two parallel lines.
So, just to be clear,
this angle, which is CAB,
is congruent to this angle, which is ACD.
And so now, we have two angles and a side,
two angles and a side, that are congruent,
so we can now deduce by
angle-angle-side postulate
that the triangles are indeed congruent.
So we now know that triangle
DCA is indeed congruent
to triangle BAC
because of angle-angle-side congruency,
which we've talked about
in previous videos,
and just to be clear,
sometimes people like
the two-column proofs,
I can make this look a little bit more
like a two column-proof by
saying these are my statements,
statement, and this is my
rationale right over here.
And we're done.